bonjour à tous je vous propose ce matin
d'écouté l'audition de bruno genevois le
président de l'agencé française de lutte
contre le dopage
il était auditionné la semaine dernière
par la commission d' enquête sur le
bilan et le contrôle de la création et
de la gestion des autorités
administratives indépendantes
cette commission présidée par la
sénatrice les républicains marie hélène
des esgaulx a été créée ici au sénat la
demande du groupe rdse
objectif établir un bilan précis de
l'activité de ses autorités
administratives et de leur utilité
juste après bruno genevois je vous
propose d'écouter une deuxième audition
celle de gérard feldzer
ce consultant aéronautique et est
auditionné dans le cadre d'une autre
commission denquête celle sur le coût
économique et financier de la pollution
de la halle à tout de suite donc on
écoute bruno genevois
donc nous recevons aujourd'hui monsieur
bruno genevois qui président de l'
agence française de lutte contre le
dopage
depuis le 1er octobre 2010 alors la
commission dans lequel sur les autorités
administratives indépendantes comme vous
le savez entend procéder à l'audition de
toutes les autorités administratives
indépendantes qu'elle a identifiée grâce
notamment aux travaux de notre ancien
collègue patrice gélard alors parmi
elles il y en a sept qui sont des
autorités publiques indépendantes qui
sont donc dotée de la personnalité
morale et monsieur bruno genevois et le
président de cette première à pays que
nous entendons nous sommes donc très
intéressé par ce que vous allez nous
dire sur la spécificité de votre statut
l'intérêt que cela représente pour vous
votre audition à travers la présentation
de l'activité de l' agence française de
lutte contre le dopage va nous permettre
de mieux apprécier les raisons de votre
création qui remonte à la loi du 5 avril
2006 qui est relative à la lutte contre
le dopage et à la protection de la santé
des sportifs comme prenant la suite
d'ailleurs du conseil de prévention et
de lutte contre le dos
baj c'est une année une haïk a été créée
par la loi du 23 mars 99 et du
laboratoire national d'ailleurs de
détection du dopage
avez-vous nous rappellerait sûrement
tous et historiques comme la loi le
permet votre audition fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié dans le compte rendu
des réunions des commissions qui est
diffusé en version papier et sur le site
internet du sida par ailleurs votre
audition est ouverte au public à la
presse et fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo avant de vous passer la parole
mais je vais respecter le format liste
des commission denquête qui me conduit à
vous demander de prêter serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant notre
commission sera passible ou saurez pas
si pardon des peines prévues aux
articles 434 13 434 15 du code pénal
en conséquence je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je jure je vous remercie
monsieur le président selon les usages
habituels je vais vous proposer de nous
faire part de vos observations durant
une dizaine de minutes après quoi
d'autres rapporteur qui viennent nous
rejoindre et j'en suis ravi jacques
mézard et les membres de la commission
qui le souhaitent vont vous poser des
questions
vous avez la parole merci madame la
présidente
mesdames les sénatrices mais celui-ci
nateur je suis à la fois honoré et
heureux d'être auditionnés par vous
alors je vais procéder à une
présentation générale de l' agence que
je préside que j'appellerais par son
acronyme la fld et comme vous venez de
l'indiquer
cette agence a été institué en tant qu
autorité publique indépendante par la
loi du 5 avril 2006 alors il n'est pas
inutile d'indiquer à titre liminaire que
la lutte contre le dopage ne remonte pas
à la loi de 2006 et n'est pas
circonscrite à la france antérieurement
la création de la fld et sans entrer
dans le détail de la législation il y
avait eu une loi du 1er juin 1965
instituant une répression exclusivement
pénale du dopage qui n'a pas donné de
bons résultats
il ya eu ensuite une loi du 28 juin 1989
qui a eu le mérite d'introduire la
notion de sanction administrative
en sus d'éventuelles sanctions pénales
en matière de dopage
la loi du 23 mars 1999 à laquelle vous
avez fait allusion qui avait institué le
conseil de prévention et de lutte contre
le dopage
le cpl des et la fld en 2006 a succédé à
cet organisme
alors on parallèle s'est développée une
réglementation sur le plan international
qui se caractérise par la coexistence de
deux types de normes qui on pratique une
très grande importance sur l'activité de
l' agence française
vous avez des conventions
internationales de type classique une
qui a été élaboré sous l'égide du
conseil de l'europe
c'est une convention du 16 novembre 1989
qui est ratifié par 52 états dont la
france et surtout une convention
élaborée sous l'égide de l'unesco le 19
octobre 2005 et qui à ce jour est
ratifié par 178 états alors cette
dernière convention se réfère aux
principes du code mondial antidopage
code mondial antidopage qui est un
document élaboré par eu l' agence
mondiale antidopage
c'est une fondation de droit privé
suisse qui a vu le jour en 1999 et qui
est co administré par les gouvernements
et le mouvement sportif
la troisième version en date de ce code
mondial antidopage est en cours de
transposition dans le droit français un
projet de loi et doit même a été adoptée
le 30 décembre 2014 habilitant le
gouvernement par ordonnance a procédé à
cette transposition alors le contexte
que je viens de rappeler permet de mieux
situer et mesurer la portée de l'action
conduite par la fld à cet égard je
voudrais développer devant vous deux
points l'un consistant à souligner les
atouts dont dispose la fld dans la lutte
contre le dopage
l'autre pour indiquer que je suis
conscient des limites de notre action et
de la nécessité de les surmonter
voyons tout d'abord brièvement les
atouts dont dispose l'agencé française
elle reste ses atouts résulte du constat
qu'en france les pouvoirs publics ont
prolongé et amplifier les efforts
accomplis par le mouvement sportif pour
lutter contre la tricherie dans le sport
l'organisation du sport en france est en
vertu d'une jurisprudence du conseil
d'état
remontant à 1974 qu alain richard
connais sûrement une mission de service
public
alors cela se traduit de façon heureuse
à un doublé gare d'abord le cadre
juridique applicable à la chance a été
définie de façon judicieuse par la loi
et d'autre par l' agence dispose de
moyens d'actions conséquents alors sur
le plan juridique les choix opérés par
le législateur avec les lois du 23 mars
1999 et du 5 avril 2006 se sont avérées
l usage bienvenus l'existence même d'une
autorité publique indépendante en charge
de la lutte contre le dopage doit être
approuvé car cette autorité n'est pas
soumise au pouvoir hiérarchique du
ministre donc de l'autorité politique et
elle est indépendante du mouvement
sportif
elle agit dans le cadre défini par la
loi
la composition du collège de l'agent ce
qui est conforme aux équilibres choisies
par le législateur dès 1999 reflète bien
le caractère pluridisciplinaire de la
lutte contre le dopage
l'agent s'est administré par un collège
de 9 mans elle peut être complété par un
dixième membres lorsqu elle examine des
affaires concernant le dopage animal les
neuf membres représentent trois
catégories de personnes des juristes du
conseil d'état et de la cour de
cassation
des scientifiques et médecins et des
représentants du monde du sport on part
égale
peut-être approuvé également la volonté
du législateur de privilégiés à l'égard
du sportif la répression administrative
du dopage sous la forme d' interdiction
de participer à des compétitions
plutôt que la répression pénale qui est
toujours assez lentes à mettre en oeuvre
et qui est réservé à la lutte contre les
trafics la compétence disciplinaire de
l' agence française de lutte conte
dopage a été défini avec soin elle est
subsidiaire et complémentaires par
rapport à celle des fédérations
sportives agréées à l'égard de leurs
licenciés si le sportif qui a fait
l'objet d'un prélèvement urinaire ou
sanguin mettant en évidence la prise de
substances interdites est poursuivi il
l'est devant les instances de sa
fédération qui doivent statuer dans un
délai global de 4 mois à peine de
dessaisissement qu'on profite de lagence
la d6 décision il y a dans le délai
légal
lagence à la possibilité d'évoquer le
dossier
si au vu d'un premier examen elle a le
sentiment que l'instance fédérale a été
soit trop clémente soit au contraire
trop sévère elle a voulu faire un
exemple
le but est d'harmoniser la répression du
dopage quelles que soient les
disciplines sportives
l'agencé est également compétente si le
sportif n'est pas licencié
elle est enfin pour étendre une sanction
fédérale propres à une discipline
déterminé à des fédérations me sport
pour éviter des fraudes à la loi alors
le système marche bien
lagence rend ses décisions en matière
disciplinaire dans un délai moyen de
quatre mois ce qui est en lien direct
avec l'intérêt d'une bonne répression
vis-à-vis des sportifs le sportif en
activité qui a fauté pourra être puni à
bon escient dans des délais raisonnables
et dans le respect des droits de la
défense alors non seulement le cadre
juridique régissant l'action de lagence
me semble pertinent mais de plus elle a
été dotée de moyens d'actions
conséquents encore qu'il faille établir
un distinguo entre l'aspect
administratif et l'aspect financier
sur le plan administratif lagence
regroupe en son sein plusieurs entités
complémentaires un département des
contrôles qui diligente des contrôles
urinaires ou sanguin un département des
analyses
c'est à dire le laboratoire qui se
trouve à châtenay malabry et qui est un
des trente trois laboratoires accrédités
par l'agencé mondiale antidopage une
cellule médicale chargée de d'examiner
des demandes d'autorisation d'usagé à
des fins thérapeutiques de dire la
possibilité pour des raisons médicales
d'avoir recours à des substances
interdites
une section juridique qui prépare
l'activité du collège en matière
disciplinaire et des services
horizontaux de coordination
nos effectifs ne sont pas pléthoriques
tant s'en faut car nous pouvons compter
sur des relais à l'échelon local
nous avons des préleveurs agréé
assermentés au nombre de 300 sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui sont des
vacataires de service public temps
partiel et nous pouvons nous appuyer sur
les services déconcentrés du ministère
en charge des sports et nous passons des
conventions à cet effet sur le plan
financier
l'appréciation de la situation est
peut-être un peu moins favorable notre
budget est de l'ordre de 9 millions
d'euros
il est financé à concurrence des neuf
dixièmes par une subvention d'origine
budgétaire
par comparaison le budget de l'agencé
mondiale antidopage et de 28 millions de
dollars seulement
dans la période récente nous avons dû
faire face à des mesures dites de sueur
gel ou de mise en réserve des crédits
qui ont affecté quelque peu notre action
mais nous essayons quand même dans ce
contexte budgétaire contraint de
maintenir et de poursuivre la mission
qui nous est confiée par la loi tout en
étant conscient des limites qu'elle
rencontre et de la nécessité de les
surmonter au mieux alors sans entrer
dans trop de détails je voudrais mettre
l'accent sur deux points essentiels de
problématique de la lutte contre le
dopage à l'heure actuelle que le sénat
connaît bien puisque une commission d'
enquête en juillet 2013 a remis un
rapport très intéressant
les deux remarques je ferai ce sera pour
dire que le code du sport privilégie des
modes de détection directe du dopage qui
débouche sur des constats qui peuvent
prêter à interprétation ou à
l'interrogation est que en tout état de
cause et c'est mon deuxième point il
faut prolonger ces modes traditionnels
de détection de diverses façons
alors la détection directe sans temps de
la mise en évidence dans les urines ou
le sang d'un sportif à l'occasion d'un
prélèvement unique d'une substance
interdite par la législation antidopage
et cette législation est la même pour
tous les sportifs car la liste des
substances interdites est établie par l'
agence mondiale antidopage chaque année
est avalisée par les gouvernements
elle fait l'objet chaque année d'un
décret du président de la république
publiée au journal officiel au mois de
décembre
applicable pour l'année suivante alors
ce mode de détection
lorsqu ils débouchent sur ce qu'on
appelle un rapport d'analysé anormal
d'ailleurs la mise en évidence de
substances interdites nous place nous
dans une situation de force
je n'ai pas les mêmes difficultés pour
réprimer les abus que l'autorité des
marchés financiers pour un délit
boursiers autre nom le sportif peut
demander l'examen d'un échantillon b qui
confirmera dans tous les cas que je
connais l'analyse de l'échantillon à il
peut aussi et surtout et c'est là dessus
que porte débat éventuellement apporter
des justifications thérapeutique en
disant que c'était nécessaire mais nous
sommes très regardants pour admettre de
telles justifications alors nous
assistons à une tendance à la diminution
du nombre de contrôles positifs qui peut
s'interpréter comme une plus grande
efficacité de l'action que nous menons
ou au contraire
compte tenu des confidences faites par
les intéressés sur des événements passés
compte tenu de ce que nous savons de la
stratégie de certains tricheurs reposant
sur la prise
micro doses très en amont des
compétitions qui ne peuvent pas être
détectées lors d'un contrôle en
compétition qui pourrait l'être dans
d'autres circonstances que la
législation développe donc face à cette
situation de départ nous essayons avec
l'aide des pouvoirs publics de compléter
le dispositif
et en ce sens il existe des possibilités
d'intervention complémentaires dont on
se doit de tirer le meilleur parti
possible alors je ne reprendrai pas sur
ce point les recommandations de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale eu
certaines ont été suivies d'effet en
particulier sur la réorganisation à
l'échelon territorial de nos modes de
contrôle
au lieu d'avoir dans chaque région des
agents de la direction régionale de la
jeunesse et des sports de la cohésion
sociale qui s'occupait à temps partiel
de la lutte contre le dopage
nous avons sur plusieurs régions des
personnels compétents les conseillers
interregio d'antidopage qui s'occupent à
100% de la lutte contre le dopage et le
trafic des produits illicites
nous essayons aussi de mieux cibler des
contrôles grâce à des échanges de
renseignements entre administrations de
l'état et nous poussons à la mise en
place effective de commissions
régionales de lutte contre les trafics
réorganisé par un décret du 26 juin 2013
cela permet aux acteurs locaux de se
connaître et de mieux cibler les
contrôles
le démarrage a été à mon avis un peu
lent mais dans la période récente il y à
un frémissement ce qui est une bonne
chose
nous essayons également de promouvoir
conformément à ce que souhaite l'agencé
mondiale antidopage des modes de
détection indirecte à travers ce que
l'on appelle sur le plan international
le passeport biologique du sportif ce
que la loi française appelle plus
justement le profil biologique
il s'agit de mettre en évidence la prise
de substances interdites
non plus à partir de l'analyse d'un
échantillon urinaire ou sanguin isolé
mais en fonction de plusieurs
prélèvements portant sur un même athlète
au cours d'une même année d'appréhender
les effets et de mettre en évidence les
effets de la prise des substances sur
l'organisme du sportif qu'il ya une
augmentation tout à fait anormales et
injustifiées des globules rouges cela
laissera supposer la prise de p&o par
exemple dans cette voie le collège de
lagence a pris des initiatives qui ont
été relayés par le parlement que je
tiens à souligner conformément aux
recommandations de l'agencé mondiale
antidopage nous avons préconisé dans une
délibération l'institution de ce mode de
détection le 27 octobre 2011
nous avons eu la bonne fortune de
bénéficier de ce qu'on appelle un
vecteur législatif avec une proposition
de loi qui a été enrichi par un
amendement du sénat président lozach qui
a introduit dans un texte qui est
devenue la loi du 12 mars 2012
le profil biologique elle création d'un
comité de préfiguration pour mettre en
oeuvre le dispositif
je présidais ce comité qui réunissait
des scientifiques le monde du sport
diverses et parlementaires également qui
a débouché sur un rapport en juin 2013
lagence a pris l'initiative de rédiger
les avant projets de décrets
d'application adoptée par son collège le
4 juillet 2013 et les pouvoirs publics
ont repris ces mesures ce sont deux
décrets du 27 décembre 2013
mettant en place ce qu'on appelle le
module hématologiques du profil
biologique c'est à dire à partir de
prélèvements sanguins au nombre d'une
dizaine sur un même sportif là
permettant la mise en évidence d'auto
transfusion sanguine ou de la prise de p
o nous avons à la suite d'autres
recommandations de l'âme a préparé un
avant projet de décret adopté par le
collège
le 3 décembre 2014
mettant en oeuvre ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le module stéroïdiens du
profil biologique à partir d'un nombre
limité d'échantillons lunaires c'est la
possibilité de mettre en évidence par
les effets sur l'organisme du sportif de
la prise d'anabolisants
le ministère des sports c'est hâter
lentement avant de transmettre ce projet
de décret au conseil d'état à la fin du
mois de mars le conseil d'état vient
d'émettre un avis favorable le 19 mai et
nous espérons peut-être très sociaux
d'aujourd'hui je n'ai pas vérifié que ce
décret sera bientôt publié nous avons
aussi été associé à la transposition de
la nouvelle version du code mondial
antidopage l'ordonance prévu par la loi
du 30 décembre 2014
le collège de lagence le 23 avril 2015 a
émis un avis très circonstancié suite à
une saisine du 10 mars précédant le
conseil d'état a été saisi du projet le
28 mai il ya un ensemble de dispositions
dans le détail dtn je n'entrerai pas
mais qui seront utiles pour lutter
contre la tricherie dans le sport alors
en conclusion et avant de répondre à vos
questions quelques très brève réflexion
je crois et j'espère vous avoir
convaincus qu'il y a tout à fait la
place en matière de lutte contre le
dopage pour une autorité publique
indépendante dans les termes que je
viens de définir mais cette autorité ne
peut pas prétendre faire cavalier seul
nous devons en permanence coordonner
notre action avec celle d'autres
autorités au plan national les
ministères principalement intéressé les
fédérations sportives au plan
international avec les fédérations
internationales et avec l' agence
mondiale antidopage
comme le disait le directeur général de
l'agencé mondiale lors d'un symposium à
lausanne auquel j'assistais nous devons
unir nos efforts et il ajoutait plutôt
que de nous crier
key mutuellement je souscris tout à fait
à ce type de propos
enfin un dernier mot pour souligner que
la fld me paraît s'inscrire
harmonieusement dans le cadre du statut
des autorités administratives
indépendantes et les autorités publiques
indépendantes défini par la proposition
de loi du doyen patrice gélard et du
président soeur à une ou deux nuances
près je vous remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur président de
cette présentation très passionnante
alors monsieur le rapporteur général
qu'est ce que ça vous vous aspirent tous
à la présidente
une question d'ordre général
compte tenu de votre longue expérience
il a été secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel président de section du
conseil d'état vous êtes donc un des
plus éminents représentants de la haute
fonction publique
je voulais avoir votre sentiment sur la
multiplication de ces autorités
administratives indépendantes comme
première question j'ai bien compris que
vous trouviez que celle que vous
présidez a une utilité évidente mais les
autres est-ce que vous quel est votre
sentiment sur ce faux ce foisonnement
j'ai appuyé sur le respect très générale
c'est que il faut éviter de trop
multiplier ce type d'autorité
afin de ne pas vider de leur substance
les administrations traditionnels donc
il faut y regarder à deux fois avant
d'en créer une
mais si on décide d'en créer une il faut
jouer pleinement le jeu
autrement dit je j'adopterai volontiers
à propos de la création des autorités
administratives indépendantes ou d
autorité publique indépendante
le mode de raisonnement qu'avait adoptée
il ya un certain nombre d'années le
conseil d'état à propos de la création
d'établissements publics ont dit les
établissements publics c'est un
démembrement de l'état c'est pas
nécessairement une bonne chose
un conseil d'état disait voyez d'abord
si l'administration traditionnelle est à
même de faire face à telle ou telle
tâche
si tel est le cas c'est pas la peine de
créer un organisme nouveau eu mais si
vous décidez le créer il faut prévoir un
statut et lui donner toutes chances de
réussite
ça c'est ma position sur un plan général
alors dans le cas particulier si vous
voulez je crois qu'il faut raisonner
autorité publique indépendante par
autorité indépendante
est ce que au cas par cas compte tenu
des éléments d'information dont on
dispose sur la manière dont ils
s'acquittent de leurs missions définies
dans le cadre législatif
elles répondent à la tante de
législateurs alors ils se trouvent et
j'ai lu votre proposition de résolution
que le parlement trouve qu'elles sont
insuffisamment contrôlées en ce qui la
concerne la fld ne se trouve pas
insuffisamment contrôlés car le hasard
des calendriers a voulu qu'il y ait
cette commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage et qui a permis de réfléchir sur
un plan global est de bien redéfinir sur
certains points l'action de la junte et
de surcroît il y a eu récemment à la
fois un contrôle comptable et de gestion
de la cour des comptes qui a trouvé son
écho dans le rapport annuel
la cour et j'aimerais vous dire que nous
avons dû répondre à beaucoup de
questions et de sollicitations de la
part de la cour mes services ont estimé
qu'il y avait eu au moins cinq mille
pages de documents transmis à la cour
toutes nos délibérations toutes les
délibérations du collège depuis la
création de la chance et nous avons
répondu et je crois que dans cette
hypothèse la cour qui doit assister le
parlement dans sa mission de contrôle
en vertu de la constitution pourrait
créer tel ou tel type de synergies et je
trouve tout à fait normal bien entendu
en tant que président de l' agence
française de répondre aujourd'hui à vos
questions merci non ce n'est pas tout à
fait répondu à une question parce que
vous nous avez dit partir du moment où
on les crée non il faut les créer à bon
escient et une fois qu'on les a créés il
faut aller jusqu'au bout devant la
question mais vous avez très bien
compris qui a été ma question c'était de
savoir votre opinion je dirais extérieur
à votre fonction de président de cette
autorité
c'était de savoir si ce que vous pensiez
de la multiplication on doit en mettre
aujourd'hui à 42 répertoriés c'est à
dire depuis que ça a commencé une part
en week et bien j'ai bien vu alors celle
ci fait d avoir la vie le seul à porter
je crois que c'est un peu autorités par
autorités la cnil créé par la loi du 6
janvier ce sont 18 répond à un besoin
eux en matière audiovisuelle
on peut penser que une instance de
régulation indépendante du politique
c'est une bonne chose
alors ensuite est-ce que le
fonctionnement répondent pleinement la
tente
l'autorité de la concurrence joue un
rôle très important dans la mise en
place certaines
politique de la concurrence donc j'ai
beaucoup de mal je suis je comprends
très bien que le parlement s'inquiète de
la multiplication
mais je ne peux répondre sur un plan
global que par la proche qui était celle
que j'ai défini la tête du conseil
d'état et dans le cas particulier de
lagence pas je pense que ça répond à une
utilité
compte tenu des dimensions à la fois
nationale et internationale de la lutte
contre le dopage
question suivante ce sera un petit peu
provocatrice et n'hésitez pas et je ne
doute pas que vous voudrez bien m'en
excuser dans beaucoup de ces autorités
indépendantes dans le collège on voit un
membre du conseil d'état allant de la
colocalisation avant de l'accord est
content
nous avons l'habitude du cumul même si
d'aucuns considèrent qu' il faut arrêter
savez je pensez vous vraiment que si on
multiplie encore ces autorités
indépendantes ces grands corps pourront
faire face
alors il ya une disposition dans le
statut de ces corps qui dit que des
fonctions non juridictionnel peuvent
être exercées aussi bien par un agent ou
un monde du corps en activité au sein du
corps que keith à honoraires et en ce
qui me concerne je suis honoré et je me
consacre pleinement à l'activité de la
présidence de lagence question était
d'ordre général alors c'est sur un plan
plus général
je crois que si on cherche par on peut
pas dire que ces personnalités en ait le
monopole mais si on cherche des
personnes qui ont une certaine
expérience administrative est une
tradition d'indépendance
ce n'est pas absurde si de surcroît en
matière sportive
le choix du vice-président du conseil
d'état 'pour ce porte sur quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse au sport de longue date
et qui n'est pas étranger au monde du
sport
bon ce n'est peut-être pas plus mal
puisque vous féliciter pour votre
habilité monsieur le président non mais
interrogé mois sur la coupe du monde de
football
le tour de france de cyclisme les jeux
olympique d'athlétisme
je puis vous montrer que ce ne sont pas
des domaines qui me sont étrangers mais
je n'en doute pas car vous avez des
compétences fortes mais d'ordre dans
tous les domaines ceci étant la question
de fond c'est de savoir vraiment quel
est le plus qu'apporte cette autorité
indépendante par rapport à l'état et aux
services de l'état
votre budget dépend vous l'avez dit
vous-même à 90 % de subventions de
l'état
on est indépendant ok mais jusqu'à quel
point quand on est dépendant à 90 % les
subventions de l'état et comment et
comment est discutée cette cette
subvention je crois que c'est un point
important
vous nous avez dit et c'est important
vous nous avez dit l' agence a rédigé
les avant projets et décrets
d'application oui tu es pour gagner du
temps et pour m'appuyer sur une
jurisprudence du conseil d'état
remontant un arrêt de 1962 martial de la
boulaye qui dit que quand on doit
consulter un organisme on est dispensé
de la consultation
s'ils organisent prend l'initiative de
la mesure leur onzième mans du grand 1
de l'article 232 5 du code du sport
prévoit que l'âge ans et consulté sur
tout projet de loi ou de règlements
relatifs à la lutte contre le dopage
alors président le comité de
préfiguration créé par la loi du 12 mars
et cette présidence je la tiens de la
volonté du législateur de l'article 5 de
la loi chez veiller à la bonne marche
des travaux et au terme des travaux
j'ai rédigé jusqu'en le monde du conseil
d'état un avant-projet de décret qui a
été approuvé par le collège ensuite
repris à son compte par le
ministère des sports examiné pour l'un
des textes par la commission
informatique et libertés et pour les
deux par le conseil d'état c'est un
supplément d'efficacité me semble-t-il
monsieur le président je vous remercie
de votre réponse
elle est absolument parfaite
et j'entends très bien à la fois votre
profonde conviction de grand serviteur
de l'état
ça je n'en doute aucunement et en même
temps je me dis c'est un fonctionnement
peut-être sur lequel il est nécessaire
que le législateur puisse s'interroger
un jour sur sur la nécessité de créer
une autorité administrative indépendante
dans ce secteur j'entends bien que vous
nous avez indiqué que c'était ça a
apporté un certain nombre d'atouts vous
l'avez dit vous-même mais quand même le
leur vous avez repris bien le
laboratoire si mes souvenirs de châtenay
malabry de châtenay malabry bon que que
fait qu'apporter vous vraiment de plus
en étant autorité administrative
indépendante par rapport à ce que peut
faire l'état vous dépendez
budgétairement presque totalement de
l'état vous avez des liens qui sont
d'ailleurs tout à fait indispensable
avec le ministère des sports
nous aussi la porte à temps et que j'ai
juste répondre là dessus j'ai évoqué l'
agence mondiale antidopage et le code
mondial antidopage dans ce code mondial
antidopage est un concept qui apparaît
c'est la notion donald l'organisation
nationale antidopage
donc il ya une organisation qui dans un
pays peut être chargés des contrôles
vous avez une agence comparable agence
française qui existe
en allemagne fédérale qui a été créée en
2002 je me suis rendu à bonn pour son
dixième anniversaire et il y avait deux
mots qui dominait les débats
una péniche kite indépendance finances
il roule problèmes de financement vous
avez une agence britannique comparable
agences françaises une agence canadienne
alors l' agence britannique à certaines
particularités elle joue davantage sur
le renseignement
et pas seulement sur les contrôle
analytique nous sommes en relation avec
ce type d' agences nous avons aussi un
stagiaire nages ont salement nous avons
envoyé un stagiaire auprès de l' agence
britannique
nous sommes réunis sur le plan
international par l' agence mondiale
antidopage son bureau j'assiste moi-même
à ce type de symposiums
il y à une unité dans la lutte contre le
dopage qui résulte de ce que sous une
même autorité nous pouvons diligenter
des contrôles au moins sur les
compétitions nationales sur les
compétitions internationales
nous sommes freinés malheureusement par
le code mondial antidopage qui donne
plutôt la compétence aux fédérations
internationales mais nous essayons de
dialoguer avec celle ci pour être
habilité à exercer des contrôles
nous avons un département des analyses
ce laboratoire accrédité qui
historiquement était un groupement
d'intérêt public qui est devenu un
établissement public administratif et
qui participe de la personnalité morale
conférer à lagence en tant qu autorité
publique indépendante
nous pouvons également superviser
l'action disciplinaire des fédérations
sportives et je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose qu'elle reste en première
ligne dans la lutte contre le dopage
avec cette contrepartie de ce pouvoir
d'harmonisation des sanctions dont nous
disposons alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que dans notre action nous sommes
obligés de coopérer avec d'autres
intervenants pour avoir une efficacité
accrue alors l'expression que j'avais
employé lorsque j'ai présenté pour la
première fois un rapport d'activité
/ agence c'est le thème de coopération
loyale que j'avais emprunté à l'union
européenne
c'est une idée il doit y avoir une
coopération loyale entre les
institutions de l'union et entre les
institutions de l'union et les états
mans et je continue d'oeuvrer dans ce
sens dans mes rapports avec les autres
administrations particulier le ministère
des sports la gendarmerie nationale qui
a un office spécialisé l'office central
de lutte contre les atteintes à
l'environnement et à la santé publique
la direction des douanes j'ai passé des
conventions en ce sens
donc voyez il ya une unité d'action qui
permet une plus grande visibilité et une
plus grande efficacité de l'action que
l'on mène et elle sut pas sûr qu'un
bureau un seul bureau au sein de la
direction des sports pourrait faire tout
ce que fait l'agent ce en revanche je
n'ai jamais nié que de l' agence ne doit
pas faire cavaliers seuls et je poursuis
toujours le dialogue la politique de
prévention est avantage l'apanage du
ministère des sports en liaison avec les
fédérations agréé dans le cadre de
contrats d'objectifs
je dois avoir des relations avec le
mouvement sportif en particulier le
comité national olympique et sportif
français
chaque année avec la commission médicale
du cnosf
nous organisons des journées consacrées
à la lutte contre le dopage je n'ai pas
le sentiment de ne pas respecter les
termes de la loi du 5 avril 2006 allez
dans le sens dijon des canaris
chardonnet où sa parole dans le sens du
rapporteur
moi même j'ai ressenti la question comme
étant quelle est la différence aussi
entre une aai haineux un pays qu'est ce
que ça vous apporte d'avoir la
personnalité juridique
alors ouais tu rêverais pour d'être calé
richert va poser aussi sa question pour
le 1er au 2
appuyez sur le micro mission essien
souplet qui nous décrit ce qui se
passerait si les décisions qui sont
prises qui sont des sanctions
administratives
on vous parle par l'autorité par l'
agence était directement des décisions
signées par le ministre des sports est
instruite sous son autorité hiérarchique
par ses services rires est-ce que
l'autorité et le sentiment
d'impartialité de ces décisions seraient
le meilleur ou moins bon
non monsieur président présidente puis
ensuite à celle de mon collègue du
conseil d'état il ya une possibilité
supplémentaire dont la possibilité
d'avoir une personnalité morale
distincte de celle de l'état
c'est la faculté de disposer
éventuellement d'une recettes affectées
et mon prédécesseur pierre bordry avait
réussi à pousser assez loin un projet
consistant à inscrire dans la loi de
finances une augmentation du taux d'une
taxe perçue sur les droits de cession
des retransmissions des grandes
compétitions sportif qui remonte à une
loi de finances de décembre 99 ce qu'on
appelle dans le monde du sport la taxe
buffet moyennant une augmentation de son
taux il y avait une affectation du parti
son montant au budget de la chance le
projet avait été assez loin il avait
reçu l'avis favorable du conseil d'état
adopté en première lecture par
l'assemblée nationale
et c'est le gouvernement qui contre
toute attente a été à l'origine d'un
amendement de suppression lors d'examens
par le sénat on a dit mais que ne dit on
pas qu'il y aurait eu une certaine
pression du monde de football auprès de
hautes autorités de l'état donc sur le
plan juridique il y a cette faculté
alors lorsque madame chantal jouanno
était ministre et que je vous en avais
parlé elle était favorable à la reprise
de lee des ses successeurs
n'ont pas repris le même la même chance
donc je j'ai des virtualités plus grande
avec un statut d'un pays mais jusqu'ici
elle se sont pas concrétisées c'est ce
que je peux répondre à votre question
alors quand alain richard je lui
rappellerai la loi de juillet 89 qui n'a
pas reçu de pratiquement d'application
je trouve qu'on a une plus forte
légitimité dans l'exercice du pouvoir de
sanction autant le pouvoir de sanction
du ministre justifie à l'égard des
fonctionnaires des agents publics
c'est l'autorité de nomination qui
détient le pouvoir disciplinaire
là vous exercer un pouvoir de sanction
vis-à-vis de tiers les habits
d'administration et vous vous substituez
d'une certaine façon un peu au juge
pénal pour deux à mon avis de bonnes
raisons il faut que ce soit quand même
par des organismes qui répondent à des
garanties des exigences d'impartialité
et d'ailleurs lagence dans ses fonctions
disciplinaire bien que ce soit au regard
du droit interne un organisme
administratif et regarder au regard de
l'article 6 de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme comme un tribunal
devant répondre aux exigences du procès
équitable
oui monsieur le président sur ses pas
une question je suis toujours gêné quand
on considère que l'état n'est pas
impartial mais ça c'est mon vieux fond
jacobins il ya des degrés dans la notion
d' à part ça l'était y compris dans la
jurisprudence des conséquences sévères
et celle du conseil d'état je ne vous la
citerai pas par coeur
mais vous allez parler de sanctions y at
il des recours contre votre wii et alors
qui sait le conseil d'état et c'est un
recours de pleine juridiction qui donne
toute garantie aux sportifs et le taux
de recours est relativement faible ce
qui prouve que nos décisions doivent
sont acceptées par les intéressés
le conseil d'état est quand même présent
vigilant et dans certaines circonstances
il lui est arrivé de nous annulé pour
des vices de procédure parce qu'on
n'avait pas laissé aux sportifs un délai
suffisant pour entre le moment où il a
eu communication du dossier la date de
réunion du collège
mais sur ce point là la cour des comptes
dans ses observations
un juge et que le fonctionnement
disciplinaire était satisfaisant et je
dirais moi comme président de l' agence
très satisfaisant donc c'est la cour des
comptes et vous-même considère que cette
satisfaisant donc sur ce plan là oui sur
ce plan là oui quand on voit le nombre
de contestations devant le conseil
d'état et le nombre de cas où nous
sommes annulé il est arrivé que tout
soyons censure et c'est sur cela vous
est-il arrivé depuis que vous présidez
monsieur le président au moins pour des
décisions d'inscription de ce qu'on
appelle sportif dans le groupe cible
nous avions interpréter les textes comme
conférence cette compétence au directeur
des contrôles et le conseil d'état a
déduit gina de l'ordonance du 14 avril
2010 modifiant l'article 232-4 du code
du sport que cette compétence devait
être exercé par le collège et il ya un
arrêt bel homme du 10 octobre 2012 ce
qui nous a censuré
les siens sur un tir groupé de jean
léonce dupont dire à cornus et jean yves
collombat alors j'ai en ai honte merci
madame la présidente
j'arrive chaque fois je me suis
collombat pardon de chaque fois me
tromper sur le prénom
pierre-yves ben oui mais jean-louis
j'étais pas pourquoi ça doit dater de
moscou ça oui oui on va tout vous dire
pierre-yves merci madame la présidente
je reviens pas sur l'idée largement
développée par le rapporteur sur les
problèmes de monoculture dont l'ensemble
des instances qui ne remet évidemment
pas en cause la qualité des personnes et
y compris en particulier de celles que
nous auditionnons et en particulier de
celles que nous auditionnons aujourd'hui
naturellement et que je respecte
profondément mais c'est un sujet sur
lequel naturellement il faudra nous
interroger je voudrais revenir en fait
sur deux points qui sont je pense de
préoccupation fondamentale la première
en réalité c'est l'indépendance et la
deuxième c'est la capacité de contrôle
donc derrière l'indépendance se pose en
particulier bien sûr notamment le
problème du financement
et derrière la capacité de contrôle
c'est clair que la qualité juridique
entraîne des contrôles qui sont de
nature différente
j'ai bien noté vous l'avez dit
habilement monsieur le président que
vous aviez été entre guillemets contrôlé
au travers d'une commission denquête il
y a quelques années et vous avez tout à
fait raison mais les commission denquête
il n'y en a pas régulièrement sur les
mêmes sujets et donc le problème qui est
posé c'est le contrôle régulier de ces
autorités administratives indépendantes
ou publique indépendante notamment par
le législateur je pense que c'est la
vraie question qui doit être posée est
donc derrière
pensez vous que par exemple un service à
compétence nationale
snc n'eut pas été plus approprié pour
répondre à l'ensemble des domaines des
questions des problématiques vous avez
soulevés mais qui permettrait parce que
c'est un service
compétences nationales un contrôle
notamment du parlement qui pourrait être
objectivement plus facile et plus
répétitif pour revenir par rapport aux
questions que le rapporteur poser tout à
l'heure les manifestations sportives ont
lieu dans tous les pays du monde et et
je suppose que tous les pays du monde
n'ont pas d' agences nationales de
dopage je voulais savoir comment ça se
passait lorsqu'à des manifestations qui
se déroulent où il n'y a pas d' agences
nationales
première question et d'autre part alors
je ne sais pas peut-être provocateur
j'en sais rien mais quels sont vos
rapports en fout agence nationale avec
l' agence mondiale et est ce que ce
n'est pas trop étriqué d'avoir une
agence nationale par rapport à
l'ensemble des manifestations sportives
et pourquoi pas une agence européenne
les rives
une remarque et puis une question la
remarque c'est que je suis toujours un
peu étonné que l'état soit tenu pour
plus partiale que ce qu'il nomme qui ce
qu'on vaut sais c'est quand même très
étonnant ma question c'est la suivante
alors aussi elle vous paraît naïve
vous mettrez sur le compte du fait que
je suis plutôt chercher liens en matière
de sport un os porte en fait vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure que votre
mission pour être une agence et cetera
s'inscrivait se justifier par le fait
que vous exercez une mission de service
public le sport tennis au service public
moi vu de l'extérieur
mon impression c'est qu'il ya au moins
deux sports deux univers sportif il ya
l'univers sportif des amateurs des vrais
et puis de plus en plus bas c'est une
usine à fric quoi c'est une entreprise
de spectacle spectacle sportif plus ou
moins de qualité
et surtout où les enjeux financiers sont
considérables
alors autant je comprends que on ait
besoin effectivement d'assurer la bonne
le bon fonctionnement du service public
de la spéciale est suivie qu'au temps je
me demande un peu ce qu'on vient faire
d'un set dans cette affaire sinon
finalement si j'exagère pour me le dire
et laisse tenter de faire croire que
tout ça tout c'est toutes ces
compétitions se passe dans le jouet dans
l' équilibre dans l'honnêteté qui a pas
de tricherie
et c'est parce qu'effectivement l'idée
de sport disons de spectacle sportif
permet quand même de sa valeur ça ne
deviendrai qu'un spectacle c'est une
question qui est quand même me
semble-t-il important parce que vu les
volumes financiers qui sont qui sont en
jeu jusque là on n'a pas parlé mais je
crois que c'est quand même une dimension
du problème tout très très intéressante
alors j'ai quelques difficultés à
répondre à la première sur le service à
compétence nationale parce que je n'ai
pas réfléchi spécialement à ce type de
problématique
ce que je puis dire quand même c'est que
chaque année auprès de chaque
commissions compétentes de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
nous avons le secrétaire-général de
l'agencé et moi un entretien avec le
rapporteur qui s'intéressent à la
mission dont relève nos crédits et ça
débouche sur des échanges qui nous
permettent de faire le point sur
l'activité d'agent ce1
donc dans le cadre de l'examen par le
parlement du projet de loi de finances
rien n'interdit un rapporteur ou même à
deux rapporteurs de la commission des
finances un rapporteur pour avis d'une
autre commission d'avoir tous éclairage
tout éclaircissement sur l'activité de
la jambe et je veux dire que pour donner
un exemple madame marie george buffet
qui était rapporteur pour avis à
l'assemblée nationale était très
heureuse de pouvoir continuer à discuter
de la problématique de lutte contre le
dopage avec les responsables de la
chance donc moi je suis très ouvert où
débat et chaque fois que l'on me l'a
demandé et que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
j'ai été auditionné par la commission
compétente sans difficulté je conçois
très bien que le parlement veuille
exercer pleinement sur son endroit car
d'ailleurs nous et nous délabre où
chaque année un rapport d'activité que
nous remettons à chaque assemblée
sortent sans difficulté alors la
deuxième question c'est que passe-t-il
se passe-t-il dans les autres pays
alors il ya les apparences flatteuse et
la réalité qui l'est beaucoup moins
alors les apparences c'est cette
convention de l'unesco sur la lutte
contre le dopage dans le sport
ratifiée par 178 états représentant plus
de 96% de la population de la planète
mais quand vous assister tous les deux
ans à la conférence des états parties de
ladite convention vous mesurer à quel
point il y à une inégalité des efforts
accomplis en matière de lutte contre le
dopage
selon les pays et selon les disciplines
eux
on a cité le nombre de laboratoires
accrédités par l'agencé mondiale
antidopage pour examiner des
échantillons ils sont 32 ou 33 parce que
laboratoire de rios a récupéré son
accréditation et y en a 18 en europe
vous en avez deux en afrique la lutte
contre le dopage suppose la lutte contre
le trafic de substances illicites
il n'ya que soixante dix états qui
réprime pénalement ce type de trafic
on pourrait poursuivre les exemples mais
moi j'en tire comme conclusion que c'est
une raison supplémentaire pour une
agence nationale
ben de d'essayer de donner le bon
exemple et de tirer parti de tout ce qui
pourrait lui permettre d'être plus
efficaces et de prendre le monde du
sport au mot alors là où il n'y a pas d'
agences nationales la compétence est
réservé aux fédérations sportives qui
font leur propre police mais dans des
conditions qui parfois ne sont pas
pleinement satisfaisante
on a parlé beaucoup récemment de la fifa
j'ai pu avoir des chiffres sur l'ampleur
des contrôles pour le mondial de
football en afrique du sud
cent mille dollars pour 256 contrôles
avant la compétition
une somme équivalente pour autant de
contrôles en compétition ce n'est pas
raisonnable ça n'est pas à la mesure de
l'événement
donc quelle doit être notre politique
c'est de le rappeler le cas échéant l'
agence mondiale le rappeler au mouvement
sportif et les dix rebelles vous êtes
croyants dans la lutte contre le dopage
essayer d'être un peu pratiquants alors
l' agence mondiale antidopage a quand
même sept grandes vertus pour nous de
pouvoir coordonner les efforts notamment
en matière de recherche ou de rassembler
un savoir faire
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le profil
biologique du sportif si nous avons pu
élaborer des avant projets de décrets
c'est en nous inspirant des lignes
directrices dégagé par l' agence
mondiale antidopage
karl a tenu ce langage au monde du sport
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'instituer le
profil biologique
mais si vous le faites vous devez suivre
mes directives donc voyez nous avons un
élément qui est très utile à cet égard
alors est ce qu'une agence européenne
donnerait plus de poids
nous essayons au sein du conseil de
l'europe
j'ai fait référence à la convention du
conseil de l'europe du 16 novembre 1989
de dégager des vues communes pour peser
d'un plus grand poids auprès de l'
agence mondiale est à l'heure actuelle
au sein du comité exécutif de l'ama
représente l'europe
madame valérie fourneyron enseigne
ministre médecin du sport et nous
oeuvrons dans ce sens la notion d'
appartient à l'it et il est évident que
cette notion d'impartialité répond à la
neutralité du service public à toute une
tradition mais l'impartialité qui est
exigée d'un juge ou d'un organisme qui
est dotée d'un pouvoir de répression
assimilable à celui d'un juge et d'un
niveau plus exigeants 1 on raisonne non
seulement en fonction d'éléments
objectifs mais aussi en fonction
d'éléments subjectifs
il ya toute une évolution en ce sens de
l'âge audience de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme donc il ya il ya des
degrés même si comme vous je suis
attachée à la continuité de l'état la
neutralité de l'état et à son
impartialité de la part d'un membre du
conseil d'état ne pas l'être ça serait
une anomalie alors sur la mission de
service public lié à l'hétérogénéité du
sport l'objection avait été formulée en
1974 devant le conseil d'état par un
membre de la juridiction
on appelait à l'époque improprement le
commissaire du gouvernement
il avait dit à la formation du jugement
vous pouvez pas reconnaître le caractère
de service public l'organisation du
sport c'est trop hétérogène et ils
avaient opposé les professionnels et les
amateurs mail avantages que j'y vois
c'est de permettre un droit de regard de
l'état y compris lorsque l'argent est
présent donc dans les rapports que j'ai
avec le monde du sport je dois pouvoir
dialoguer non seulement avec la
fédération française de football mais
aussi avec la ligue professionnelle et
après demain je vais recevoir plusieurs
représentants des groupements
professionnels pour débattre avec eux de
la lutte contre le dopage
si vous le permettez je j'en suis fini
quand même par me demander si vous
n'êtes pas absolument indispensable pour
laisser croire ou laissé entendre que
finalement tout ça se déroule
normalement et que donc on peut
continuer à croire à la fiction de
compétition qui sont des compétitions
alors que reprendre une expression ce
sont des spectacles des spectacles qui
rapporte beaucoup d'argent
si vous n'êtes cia pas la persistance de
ce sentiment que les compétitions sont
honnêtement menées çà çà mais tout par
terre alors il ya deux aspects dans la
lutte contre page du point de vue du
législateur est un impératif de santé
publique qui est tout à fait présent
lorsqu'une substance est rangé par les
substances interdites aux pour dire en
raison de ses effets néfastes sur la
santé des intéressés et qui est
interdite aussi bien qu'aux compétition
qu'à l'entraînement puis un deuxième
aspect qui est d'éviter que il ya une
atteinte à l'éthique du sport et que par
des procédés détourné au lieu d'avoir
une lutte entre des athlètes
on est des luttes entre des laboratoires
qui fabriquerait des substances
permettant des améliorations
artificielle de performance alors nous
nous prenons le monde du sport au pied
de la lettre
en nous appuyant sur la loi française et
en et en contrôlant aussi bien les
compétitions amateurs que les
compétitions professionnelles et nous
étions présents pour contrôler les
joueurs de la dernière finale de
la coupe de la ligue l'année dernière de
la coupe de france cette année
1 il ne faut pas faire apparaître qui
auraient des domaines qui serait à
l'abri du contrôle en matière de lutte
contre le dopage
quelles que soient par ailleurs les
moyens financiers et les enjeux
financiers
une agence indépendante n'a pas peur
d'intervenir même si des enjeux
financiers sous jacents sont en cause je
vais donner par la mission one qui l'a
demandé vous vous réunissez tous les
combien de cas les membres du collège
alors les membres sont nommés pour une
durée de 6 ans et un renouvellement par
tiers tous les deux ans la loi prévoit
qu'il peut y avoir deux mandats
successifs
ce qui sur ce point se sépare un peu de
la proposition de loi
mais la proposition de loi de manière
judicieuse prévoit que si on remplace un
membre pour un mandat de moins de deux
ans
on peut concourir pour un nouveau mandat
alors je vous rassure en ce qui me
concerne
j'arrêterai mes fonctions à l'expiration
de son mandat le moment d' aimer
dernière petite observation moi j'ai une
crosse du sud ouest voilà chez moi et
j'attend toujours d'ailleurs souvent
injouable
la course des élites l'aller les as la
course des as ça s'appelle comme ça pour
remettre les récompenses j'attends
justement parce qu'il ya un contrôle
antidopage
des fois il a lieu des fois y'a pas lieu
alors c'est vous qui décidez de ce vous
le faites vous faites pas c'est qu'ils
vraiment qu'ils décident de faire le
contrôle ou pas alors il ya le collège
de l'agent ce qui définit chaque année
un programme général de contrôle
d'accord avec un certain équilibre entre
sport individuel sport collectif qu'on
veut c'est le collège qui pousse des
colères et à l'intérieur de ce cadre
c'est le directeur du département des
contrôles qui peut recueillir des
informations auprès des administrations
de l'état qui détermine la stratégie des
contrôles camp mais ça reste secret ça
reste sympa dial entendu il ne s'est pas
vu c'est imprévisible miocène évidemment
et nous avons une déconcentration de la
politique nous laissons un quota
deux possibilités de contrôle henry aux
échelons régionaux ou interrégionaux et
c'est pour ça que dans mon exposé
liminaire
j'ai insisté sur les commissions
régionales parce que ça permet des
échanges d'informations entre les
diverses administrations de l'état pour
mieux cibler les contrôles
alors avant de redonner la parole aux
rapporteurs mais si twente
oui juste de deux questions mineures la
première porte sur l'information que
vous nous avez donné
constatant que le nombre de contrôle
positif était en régression et vous avez
eu d'ailleurs l'on était de dire que
c'était pas forcément parce que la
situation s'améliorait mais parce que
les tricheurs et est devenu de plus en
plus intelligents ou tout au moins qu'il
disposait de technologies et de
techniques qui étaient plus
difficilement détectables plus de plus
difficilement détectables et vous avez
d'ailleurs ajouter aussi que il
convenait d'avoir des contrôles
indirects et par conséquent d'intervenir
plus en amont ma question c'est mais ça
ne va pas empêcher les tricheurs de
continuer à vouloir tricher parce que ce
qu'on a relevé tout à l'heure au bout
c'est de la compétition et au bout il ya
de l'argent il ya de l'argent important
pour ce qu'ils sont qui sont les
champions et ce qui les amène à la
situation de champion comment est ce
qu'on peut comment est-ce que l' agence
peut s'adapter en permanence voire
anticiper sur ce qui va se passer
est ce que vous êtes à l'affût de la
recherche médicale de tout ce qui peut
sortir en la matière et qui peut
éventuellement générer de l'utilisation
abusive et la deuxième observation vous
avez dit également
alors si vous voulez vous n'avez pas de
façon explicite mais implicitement je
vous avais laissé entendre que les
sanctions qui sont administrés par l'
agence ne doivent être plutôt juste
puisqu'elles sont acceptés
cette relation de cause à effet ne me
paraît pas évidente parce que on peut
très bien accepté une sanction en se
disant on a échappé au pire si on était
passé ailleurs on aurait été sanctionné
de façon beaucoup plus grave
est ce que le fait que vous affirmiez ça
ne recèle pas une indulgence un peu trop
importante ou bien est-ce que
il ya d'autres raisons à ce constat
merci pour vos deux de très pertinente
question je crois avoir indiqué que dans
mon esprit il y avait un recul du dopage
organisé
nous rendons la tâche toujours plus
difficile aux tricheurs alors il faut
anticiper dans ce sens
l' agence mondiale antidopage en liaison
avec le ministère des sports avait
organisée c'était dans les locaux de
l'assemblée nationale
mais le sénat mais il verra pas
mauvaises manières le 12 novembre 2012
un colloque regroupant les grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et les
acteurs de la lutte antidopage incitant
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques à faire
connaître aux laboratoires accrédités
par l'agencé mondiale antidopage des
médicaments en cours d'élaboration
contenant des substances considérées
comme dopantes
on regarde la réglementation antidopage
de telle façon que les laboratoires
accrédités puissent réfléchir et
travailler par avance aux méthodes de
détection politique que je trouve
excellente
le seul problème c'est que ça repose sur
le volontariat
donc les laboratoires pharmaceutiques le
veuille alors ils peuvent y avoir un
intérêt pour lutter contre le marché
noir de certaines substances
j'ai regretté que le laboratoire de
châtenay malabry ne soient mis à
contribution quand deux circonstances
au titre de ce type de recherche
mais c'est incontestablement une piste à
explorer pour être en avance ou pas en
retard sur les tricheurs alors sur le
deuxième point sur le caractère juste ou
non des sanctions
j'ai raisonné en tant que juriste les
décisions prises par le collège sont
considérées comme légales ou bien fondé
par le conseil d'état alors ça veut dire
que
j'agis dans le cadre de la loi ça ne
veut pas dire que je sois ou que le
collège placé sous ma présidence soit
laxiste ce qui conduirait le sportif à
ne pas contester au contraire il y en a
un certain nombre qui conteste mais leur
requête peut être écartée 1-1 tout
récemment il ya un sportif qui avait été
contrôlé à le p o qui avaient été
évincés des jeux olympiques de londres
qui a critiqué qui a été devant le
conseil d'état
conseiller talent le 5 mai 2015 à
rejeter sa requête
1 donc ne nous prenne ne nous méprenons
pas j'agis légalement ça ne veut pas
dire que nous agissons avec une trop
grande mansuétude non nous nous référons
aux critères du code mondial antidopage
simplement il n'y a pas d'automatisme
absolue qui serait contraire impôts
droit français on doit quand même tenir
compte des circonstances plus le
rapporteur alors deux petites questions
qu'une il m'arrive d'être têtu monsieur
le président pensez vous par exemple que
sur la lutte contre le travail dissimulé
il serait bon de créer une autorité
administrative indépendante avec un
collège dans lequel il y aurait outre
des représentants de la haute fonction
publique le medef et la cgt lui
considère je vous répondrai que en
matière de travail nous avons des
conventions de l'oit est un qui
confèrent une indépendance aux
inspecteurs du travail et que cette
indépendance des inspecteurs du travail
a été reconnue par un arrêt du 4
novembre 1966 du conseil d'état statuant
au contentieux
donc si vous avez une institution qu'est
l'inspection du travail
doté d'un statut d'indépendance reconnue
tant par une convention de l'oit et que
par la violence interne
a priori il faut miser sur l'inspection
du travail et développer ses effectifs
et je ne recommanderais pas en l'état de
créer une autorité publique indépendante
en ce domaine
la dépendance est d'ores et déjà assurée
je vous remercie de la réponse qu'il ne
s'agissait pas totalement aux en douter
une question pour sur le dopage
et celle là elle est sans elle et pas du
tout gros catrice nous avons tous comme
citoyen vécu les annonces médiatiques
concernant le dopage de grands seigneurs
du tour de france annoncent chaire est
tardive
avez vous fait quelque chose parce que
bon faut pas se leurrer on voit bien que
dans certains sports il ya depuis très
longtemps et en dépit de tout ce qui ce
de tous les efforts qui sont faits
d'abord par l'état mais aussi souvent
par le monde sportif
il ya quand même une constante dans la
continuation du dopage mais pour en
revenir à cet exemple qui est quand même
très important puisque c'est quand même
l'image numéro 1 1 dans le monde du
sport français
est ce que vous avez fait quelque chose
et si oui quand même s'est pas alors je
réponds bien volontiers le tour de
france est une manifestation
internationale
d'après le code mondial antidopage
l'article 15
c'est la fédération internationale qui
est normalement compétente alors la
fédération internationale peut décider
d'agir seul elle peut aussi décider
d'agir par voie de convention avec une
agence nationale
le code mondial antidopage prévoit
également une agence nationale même pour
une compétition internationale peut
demander à faire des contrôles
supplémentaires supplémentaires
s'ajoutant à ceux de la fédération
internationale si la fédération
internationale n'est pas d'accord on
peut solliciter un arbitrage de l'
agence mondiale antidopage lors la
politique de l' agence depuis
je suis président a consisté
conformément d'ailleurs aux
recommandations faites le 6 novembre
2010 par les experts de l'ama qui avait
supervisé le tour de france 2010 à
rechercher un accord avec l'union
cycliste internationale nous avons pu
déboucher sur un accord et le
perfectionner du moins nous le pensons
d'année en année le perfectionner ça
veut dire que les contrôles ne doivent
pas avoir lieu seulement pendant le tour
ils doivent pouvoir se dérouler en amont
grâce à une bonne connaissance de la
localisation des sportifs grâce à un
échange d'informations entre l' agence
nationale et la fédération
internationale sur le profil biologique
des sportifs pour mieux cibler les
contrôles
nous avons passé des conventions en ce
sens nous prévoyons des contrôles aussi
inopinées possible pendant la durée de
l'épreuve et nous avons insisté aussi
auprès de l'union cycliste
internationale plus précisément de la
fondation antidopage dans le cyclisme
qui relève de l'union cycliste
internationale pour que soient annoncés
à l'avance une politique consistant à
conserver des échantillons pour des
analyses ultérieures
bénéficiant des progrès de la technique
sur le modèle de ce que fait le comité
international olympique pour les jeux
olympiques donc dans mon esprit de bon
contrôle antidopage repose sur des
contrôles en amont de la compétition
pendant la compétition sur l' annonce du
stockage d'échantillons en vue d'
analyse ultérieure bénéficiant des
progrès techniques et nous ne donnons
pas un autre langage avec l'union
européenne de football association
dans la perspective de l'eurofoot qui
aura lieu en france l'année prochaine
mais nous sommes en cours de discussion
merci notre question des questions mes
chers collègues on peut considérer que
nous sommes parfaitement éclairé sur la
fld mais merci beaucoup monsieur le
président qu'il très précisément ces
interrogations
merci beaucoup